In Serbia, a dense morning fog led to two multiple vehicle crashes on a key highway,...
...which killed six people and injured at least 27, according to Serbian police.
In the US, Nikki Haley has resigned as the US ambassador to the UN.
Haley's reason was "to take some time off,"...
...and she met with President Trump to address her decision.
In El Salvador, flooding has killed three people...
...and has caused more than 700 to evacuate the country.
The intense rainfall is also affecting other countries,...
...such as Honduras, Costa Rica and Nicaragua.
In Russia, the Trans-Siberian Railway had a bridge collapse on it...
...in the city of Svobodny, damaging one train.
The reason for the collapse was not immediately clear.
Finally, more than 12,000 people were evacuated...
...after ammunition started exploding during a massive fire...
...in an arms depot in northern Ukraine, according to authorities.